[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في العاده يوصف الاقتصاد والشؤون
الماليه وما يرتبط بها بالدقه والبعد عن
الاهواء والاساليب الانشائيه لكن ما تراجه
منذ بدايه الازمه الخليجيه الراهنه اوساط
قد تكون لبعضها علاقه بالماليه والمحاسبه
بينما لا تمت اليهما اخرى بصله كبيره نسف
تلك المقوله جمله وتفصيله قيل عن تراجع
قيمه الريال القطري كثير مسموعا ومقروء
فما وجه الصحه او الخطا في معالجه هذا
الموضوع وكيف نالت بعض وسائل الاعلام من
مكانه الريال القطري وقيمته في الاسواق
الماليه في اطار الحمله على قطر
حاتم غندير لديه
المزيد ما حقيقه تراجع الريال القطري
ولماذا يتم تضخيم اخبار تراجع الريال في
السوق الدوليه الموازيه هل هي السياسه ام
الاقتصاد من يحرك اخبار الريال لنب بسط
الحكايه معلوم ان الريال القطري مرتبط
كليا بالدولار بسعر ثابت مقداره ثلاثه
ريالات و64 درهما منذ عام 81
9 في مجال تداول العملات الفوركس هناك
سوقان السوق النظامي او ما يعرف بالاون
شور ماركت وهو السوق الرسمي في قطر حيث
العمله ثابته في جميع البنوك القطريه كما
هو محدد من قبل المصرف المركزي السوق
الخارجي اوف شور ماركت وهو للبنوك
الخارجيه مفتوح طوال السنه ويعمل على مدار
اليوم لا يغلق في اي وقت من الاوقات
والعمله متغيره بشكل طفيف
في حاله الاجازه التي صادفت ايام العيد
وفي عطله المصرف المركزي القطري نشط السوق
الخارجي تحت عوامل سياسيه اذ كانت هناك
رغبه في بيع العمله بهامش ربح كبير ما خفض
من سعر الريال في فتره محدده وبنحو 3% ثم
ارتفع الريال بعد ذلك ليبقى الفارق بين
السوقين واح في وماذا بالنسبه الى سوق
العمله الداخلي السعر ثابت والدولار يعادل
3 ريالات و644 درهما والريال القطري يعتبر
من اقوى العملات في الخليج لانه مدعوم
باقتصاد متين وميزان مدفوعات قوي
واستثمارات ضخمه في الداخل والخارج
واحتياطي نقدي كبير من العملات الاجنبيه
وماذا عن رفض بعض البنوك التداول بالريال
في بريطانيا كما اشع المساله محض تضخيم
اعلامي لكن لماذا التعامل بالريال القطري
محدود جدا في الخارج من يتعامل به هم
افراد لاغراض السفر وبمبالغ صغيره اما
المؤسسات القطريه الحكوميه والخاصه كلها
تتعامل بالدولار في الخارج وبالتالي فان
التعامل بالريال في الخارج لا يكاد يذكر
ولا تاثير له فعليا على سعر
العمله المصرف المركزي القطري اعلن انه
سيضمن كل عمليات الريال داخل قطر وخارجها
ودون
تاخير لان كل العوامل الاقتصاديه التي
تؤدي الى تراجع الريال القطري منتفه ما
يعني ان هناك طرفا ثالثا اشارت له كل
المصارف التي علقت التداول بالريال ولم
تسميه وهو من لم يزود تلك المصارف بالعمله
الريال لكن مصادر خاصه ذكرت للجزيره ان
هذا الطرف هو شركه ترافلكس التي استحوذت
عليها شركه اماراتيه ومقرها ابو ظبي في
عام
2015 مقابل مليار دولار وهو ما يطرح اكثر
من سؤال وما يعني ايضا ان قضيه العمله
القطريه التي تثار في الاخبار ليست سوى
حرب نفسيه تسعى دول الحصار لاثارتها تماما
كما هي شائعات تجميد الاصول القطريه في
هذه الدول في حال لم تستجب قطر لمطالبها
وهنا يكون فعل الاقتصاد سلاحا ذا حدين لن
يضر المحاصر فقط الذي كسب المعركه
دبلوماسيا واخلاقيا وانما سينال من دول
الحصار ذاتها التي حاولت ان تبني سمعه
اقتصاد
بدات اليوم تنهار مع كل يوم يضاف الى عمر
الحصار لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الدوحه الخبير المالي والاقتصادي قاسم
محمد قاسم وفي الاستوديو بشير الكحلوت
مستشار اقتصادي ومدير مركز البيرق
للدراسات الاقتصاديه والماليه اهلا بضيفي
ابدا معك السيد بشير الكحلوت اشاعات كثيره
منذ بدايه الازمه الاقتصاديه او الازمه
الخليجيه تستهدف تحديدا الجانب الاقتصادي
والاقتصاد القطري بشكل عام هل استطاع
هذا الحصار فعلا التاثير على قيمه الريال
القطري الحمد لله ويمكرون ويمكر الله
والله خير الماكرين يعني رغم كل ما سمعنا
في هذا التقرير الجيد قبل قليل
اي الا انه لم تنجح كل هذه المحاولات على
الاطلاق في البدايه تصادف
اي اجازه موسم الاجازات
ورمضان وكان هناك طبعا كما هو معروف زياده
غير عاديه في الطلب على الدولارات الاول
نبدا بسعر صرف
ال ب التحويل يعني وكان هذا
بدايه متوقعه يعني ولكن مع الازمه بدات
وكان هناك طلبات اكثر من اللازم على بعض
المحلات طبعا كل محل كل شركه بيكون لديها
ستوك لمواجهه الطلبات عادي يعني ولكن في
ظل التطورات وموسم الاجازات بدا وكان هناك
شح في المتاح ولكن هذا لم يستمر الا لايام
قليله وانتهى
و عندما بدات اجازه العيد وهي اجازه على
غير العاده كانت طويله هذا
العام هنا بتتوقف شركات والبنوك المحليه
عن التعامل و كما ذكر التقرير هناك سوق
اوف شور انشور سوق فورورد وسوق سبوت ف
تقتصر التعاملات على الاسواق العالميه لمن
يريد التعامل عاده الناس ما بتكون بس يعني
اذا هذه هي الاسباب واصبحت الان واضحه
لذلك ما يو ما وصف ربما بالتراجع الطفيف
لقيمه الريال انقل هذه الانشغالات الى
السيد قاسم محمد قاسم وهو خبير مالي ينضم
الينا هنا من الدوحه سيد قاسم ربما لجات
اطراف الى محاوله التاثير على قيمه الريال
بسحب الريال القطري من محلات الصرافه
تحديدا في بريطانيا ما الجدوى من هذه
الخطوه باعتقادك ربما
تحديدا لان الريال القطري لا يكاد يذكر
وجوده في محلات الصرافه تلك هو في الحقيقه
كما ذكر التقرير وكما ذكرت للتو لا جدوى
من ذلك لانه التعامل بالريال القطري كبنك
نوت في الخارج محدود جدا ويقتصر الى حد
كبير على المسافرين القطريين حتى
المسافرين القطريين في كلهم وفي اغلبهم
واعين يعتمدوا على الريال او العمله
الالكترونيه كل مسافر في جيبه اي كريديت
كارد وبجيبه اي تي ام ويستطيع ان يذهب الى
اي صرافه وياخذ الدولار الذي يريد من
حسابه في قطر بالسعر الذي يحدده البنك
القطري وبالتالي
اي لا لا يوجد او لم يكن هناك اي داعي ولا
ضروره لان يخاف اي حائز على الريالات
القطريه يستطيع ان يحتفظ بها بجيبه ويذهب
الى الصرافي وياخذ او يكلم لا تاثير
لانه ال وسائل التحويل والحصول على
السيوله للمسافر متاحه انما القضيه قضيه
تشويش وبلبله ابقى معك سي محمد قاسم اذا
هو تشويش وبلبله واجهها المصرف المركزي في
قطر باطمان وقال انه ملتزم بضمان كل
التعاملات الداخليه والخارجيه بالريال
باعتقادك ما الحلول المتاحه امام مصرف قطر
المركزي لابقاء استقرار الريال القطري
الحلول هي متاحه وموجوده
وتتمثل بعوامل قوه الريال وخصائصه قطر
اقتصاد قوي احتياطي نقدي ضخم جدا يغطي
النقد المصدر بعده اضعاف وايضا الريال
القطري مرتبط بالدولار عن طريق البيج تو
ذا دولار في ميكانزم من سنه 81 كما ذكر
التقرير ولا يوجد هناك اي نيه لفك هذا
الارتباط بل ان عملات اربع دول اخرى ايضا
في مجلس التعاون اي تنتمي الى هذا النظام
للربط بالدولار ولا يعتقد اي مصرفي في
المنطقه بامكانيه فك هذا الارتباط لانه لا
مصلحه لا لقطر ولا للدول الاخرى في مجلس
التعاون لفك هذا الارتباط وبت وهذه الدول
دول الحصار انقل الان الفكره الى ضيفي هنا
سيد بشير الكحلوت دول الحصار باتت تهدد
الان مع اقتراب انتهاء المهله المذكوره
وهي ع ايام تهدد باجراءات اقتصاديه اكثر
شده تتحدث عن سحب ودائعها الماليه من قطر
ما بد تاثير هذه الخطوه ان تمت
يعني بالنسبه للجهاز المصرفي في قطر اخر
الارقام المتاحه سنه لابريل سنه 2017 كانت
بتشير الى ان موجودات ومطلوبات هذا الجهاز
تصل الى
1308 مليار
ريال وبالتالي نحنا لو نظرنا الى المبالغ
اللي بيتحدث عنها وذكرتها جريده اليوم
السابع من حوالي ثلاث اسابيع في القاهره
بيتكلموا عن 16 مليار دولار او 60 مليار
ريال فاذا كنت تتحدثي عن 60 مليار مليار
وسط 1308 مليار فلا تاثير على الاطلاق
خاصه لو نظرنا الى ان
ال الاقتصاد القطري بطبيعته ليس من دول
العجز وانما هو من دول الفائض الميزان
التجاري الشهري لدوله قطر يولد فائض لا
يقل عن 10 مليار ريال رغم انخفاض اسعار
الن واذا استمرت هذه الازمه سيد محمد قاسم
ما هو الضمان للابقاء على هذا الاستقرار
تحدثت عن جمله عوامل منها الملاءه الماليه
الكبيره لقطر وكذلك ارتباطه الثابت
والمستمر بالدولار الامريكي الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يستمر هذا الصمود اذا ما طال امد
الازمه يعني ايضا كما ذكر زميلي قطر من
دول الوفره وصادراتها من المنتجات الغاز
والطاقه مستمره ولم تنقطع
وقنوات التصدير مفتوحه قد تكون هناك من
وقت الى اخر صعوبات في اعاده التزود
بالوقود او اخرى وهذه الصعوبات امر طبيعي
في مثل هذه الظروف ويجري التعامل معها انا
اعتقد انه مثل هذه الامور اخذت في
الاعتبار منذ بدايه الازمه ان لم يكن
قبل ذلك لا خوف في اعتقادي بدون شك هناك
صعوبات لكن هذه الصعوبات يجري التعامل
معها وبنجاح قاسم محمد قاسم الخبير المالي
من الدوحه وبشير الكحلوت المستشار
الاقتصادي ومدير مركز البيرق للدراسات
الاقتصاديه والماليه شكرا جزيلا لمشاركتك
ما هذا الجانب من مناقشه اخر ملف من حصاد
الليله شكرا لكم متابعه شكرا
لمتابعتكم ملفات حصاد هذه الليله الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ان